bonsoir jean claude galien merci de
répondre aux questions vous qui êtes
spécialiste en communication politique
comment est-ce que vous analysez le body
language de cet après midi entre
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine
d'ailleurs n'y a pas eu de deux poignées
de mains entre les deux hommes il était
assis à table et avec une très très
grande table alors oui la grande table
il ya effectivement des mesures qu'on
peut comprendre concernant la
l'épidémie la pandémie encore ray
justifié il ya aussi une période de
tension très forte qui n'est pas
seulement des tensions entre la rue six
états unis mais une partie de l'europe
aussi avec la russie emmanuel macron et
de la lumière poutine sont très éloignés
on voit bien cette espèce de mise en
théâtre mais il faut savoir que viktor
orban qui a été reçue récemment par le
président poutine était assis de la même
manière autour de cette même grande
tablée donc pourtant les relations entre
viktor orban et martin sont certainement
un peu meilleures qu'elles ne le sont
avec emmanuel macron en tout cas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui donc il faut pas
surinterpréter je pense malgré tout
cette cette disposition très théâtralisé
est ce que vous attendez de la
conférence de presse conjointe qu'il va
avoir lieu d'ici 30 à 45 minutes mais on
sait qu'il ya toujours un peu de retard
également quels éléments de langage est
ce qu'il faudra scruter escurat des
tournures de phrases a analysé également
selon vous
moi je pense qu'on est à la recherche de
quelque chose qui ressemble en
diplomatie vous savez on découpe les les
enjeux on l'est on les compartiments tu
es donc là il ya une volonté mon avis de
part et d'autre de beaucoup on parlait
de la désescalade président poutine a
exprimé l'idée qu' il est il salué les
efforts de la france président de
l'europe effectivement il faut savoir
qu'au plaisir bodine a toujours dit
qu'il s'est compliqué de discuter avec
l'europe parce qu'il y avait toujours
une polyphonie au lieu d'avoir une seule
voie et donc on a un retour aussi de
l'europe malgré tout dans la
conversation diplomatique autour de
cette crise
donc on est déjà dans des apports
respectifs c'est à dire qu'on a bouger
des lignes maman est-ce que ça va se
traduire de manière concrète par des
mots forts
je n'y crois pas je pense par contre
qu'il y a une volonté
partagée
d'ouvrir de réouvrir une conversation et
qu'ils soient pas simplement une
conversation si vous voulez de voilà de
diplomatique au sens où on fait des
effets politiques de part et d'autre
pour des marchés intérieurs vladimir
poutine pour la russie ou pour une
partie de ses alliés et emmanuel macron
pour le marché français notamment en
période électorale où une partie des
européens donc on est face à quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus sérieux dans
ce cas on l'espère et avec une volonté
commune de progresser il y a il y a
potentiellement encore une fois des
défis des petits pas qui doivent être
faits qui ne sont plus possibles
semble-t-il en dehors de ce type de
conversation et donc il faut il faut se
réjouir que ça a pu avoir lieu ne pas
attendre
de grandes nouvelles
mais espérer qu'il ne s'agit pas
simplement d'un rendre juste de
communication justement diplomatiques ou
politiques pour que ça puisse
effectivement petit à petit trouver une
solution à la crise qui est quand même
très tendu certains opposants d'emmanuel
macron dénonce ce choix de se rendre à
moscou jean luc mélenchon a plaidé hier
soir pour la désescalade il a appelé à
ce que la france ne soit pas aligné
notamment sur washington valérie
pécresse a appelé ce matin je cite le
fier peuple russe à ne pas envahir
l'ukraine s'est d'ailleurs exprimé en
russe en quoi cette rencontre peut-elle
jouer sur la présidentielle en france
qui est spécialiste des campagnes
politiques
alors
encore une fois je pense qu'il faut
vraiment espérer qu on est dans un
processus diplomatique
moi je suis assez je l'espère je pense
qu'il ya peut-être effectivement la
france a à travers l'europe on peut
estimer qu'elle est aussi un brave
négociations entre deux gros blocs qui
se font face maintenant
réjouissons nous de cette capacité est
ce que ça doit impacter la campagne
électorale française bien sûr que ça
peut impacter si jamais il y avait une
bonne nouvelle voyez si j'avais emmanuel
macron pouvait revenir à l'issue de sa
tournée avec des vrais pas réaliser
c'est une manière d'effacer
une forme de baisse de la cotation
française en matière diplomatique c'est
à dire que il ya eu les effets de l'inde
au pacifique au tour de l'australie et
autour du sous marin il y à l'idée que
l'europe et n'étaient pas associés à la
conversation russo américaines entre
l'otan en particulier et la russie ces
derniers temps donc on y voit là il ya
forcément quelque chose qui peut se
passer de manière positive si jamais il
ya des résultats à défaut d'être concret
et qui en tout cas montrent une
progression et ça effectivement
emmanuel macron à part et non pas
simplement comme un chef de la
diplomatie européenne en l'occurrence
mais aussi un chef finalement peut-être
n'ont pas de guerre parce que espérons
le on n'est pas dans quelque chose qui y
ressemble à ça aujourd'hui mais qui est
leur positionne comme un partenaire
important
géopolitique dans une zone où pour
l'instant l'europe et la france en
particulier était un peu exclu et vivait
en deuxième niveau voir sur le banc des
remplaçants de quelque chose qui se
jouait entre l'otan dont les etats-unis
et la russie
outre l'ukraine évidemment principal
enjeu des négociations d'aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que la france a négocié
directement avec la russie elle
nucléaire du côté de belfort et le mali
avec la force takouba c'est que
l'allemagne doit également négocier le
gaz avec la russie qui a les cartes en
main est ce que c'est pas risqué pour
emmanuel macron de négocier si seul qui
a le plus à perdre ou à gagner
alors c'est vrai que il ya des zones de
friction
direct je pense vous l'avez cité au
sahel et en particulier au mali où il ya
il ya une sur le clairement il ya une
lutte
d'influencé diplomatique géopolitique
que certains d'ailleurs
condamne parce que notamment les
populations des différentes zones ou en
tout cas certains dirigeants considèrent
qu'il ne s'agit pas pour eux de devenir
un nouveau terrain d'affrontement entre
blocs de puissance
il n'en reste que c'est réel après vous
avez raison de le dire il ya un enjeu
européen qui est parfois créer des
divisions très forte entre notamment
trois parties je dirais qu'il ya une
partie qui laisse de l'europe je pense
notamment à la pologne à la roumanie à
certains d'autres des tabous ne mettrait
pas la hongrie passe quand une fois on a
vu votre chose se passait mais qui y
cherche un appui extrêmement affirmé
notamment dans une liaison avec les
états unis extrêmement forte donc d'une
occidentalisation notamment delà de la
position européenne ya l'allemagne qui
évidemment un enjeu énergétique qui a
finalement décidé quelque part de la
relation bilatérale mais quelque part
aussi multilatéral de l'europe avec la
russie puisque le nord stream 2 qui est
un enjeu majeur de la relation encore
une fois énergétique entre la russie et
l'union européenne vient impacter très
fortement l'équilibré aussi là aussi des
positions en europe et puis à la france
qui au delà du mali au delà du sel a
entamé un processus une tentative de
rapprochement avec la russie déjà il ya
très longtemps votre sujet le montrer
juste avant mais qui en même temps on le
sent bien et là il faut interroger vous
voir ce qui va se passer dans les
quelques semaines qui viennent pourrait
aussi lorsqu'on ça aux troupes qui
pourrait envoyer française en roumanie
ou en pologne pourrait avoir un rôle
plus important dans le cadre d'un
dispositif autant c'est à dire dans
quelque chose qui se relie plus
fortement aux etats unis donc on n'est
pas dans une période d'incertitude est
ce qu'on a une position d' équilibre de
la france à la tête de l'union
européenne pour quelques mois est-ce
qu'on a une position d'équilibré de la
france seule dans un contexte de
rapports à la russie qui parfois
conflictuelles ou est-ce qu'on a quelque
chose qui tourne plutôt vers les états
unis voyez en étant quelque part le
gestionnaire délégué dans la zone
européenne d'affaires que les américains
ne peuvent plus gérer parce que
finalement aujourd'hui ils sont happés
est largement happé par la relation à la
chine et notamment dans la zone du
pacifique et de l'inde au pacifique il
ya beaucoup d'incertitude on a pas on
n'a pas les clés ce qui est certain
c'est qu'à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne ya sinon des zones de
fractures beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
positions qu'ils sont ne pas aligner et
ça ça ne doit pas facilité la tâche des
manuels macro m'ont pas simplement en
face de valdimir poutine mais
lorsqu'il va revenir prêts des européens
et imaginons bien que la diplomatie
russe connaît tout ça par coeur et sur
le bout des doigts merci jean christophe
gallien d'avoir été avec nous sur arte
france on rappelle que vous êtes
politologue communicants enseignant à
l'université de la sorbonne et président
de jcj assez